je veux dire c'est même où d'entendre
encore des mots de confinement de
restriction quant on connaît les
conséquences économiques sociales
monsieur la ford dit dans cette
interview pour les retrouver sur
franceinfo.fr il ya jamais eu autant de
suicides qu'en ce moment la dépression
économique est majeur nous avons des
étudiants qui sont en situation
cataclysmique
nous avons les problèmes psychiatriques
même bonnaire doit le savoir si les prix
stables sur la situation nous sommes
d'accord qu est ce que vous proposez moi
je dis là pour proposer au bout d'un
moment si vous voulez einstein disait la
folie c'est de faire toujours la même
chose en disant qu'au bout d'un moment
ça va avoir des conséquences différentes
man ou le confinement effectivement il
ya un an on savait par an tâtonner dans
sa marche pas il faut regarder les pays
qui en dehors de la france dans le monde
ont fait autrement et qui ont des
résultats meilleurs alors qu'ils n'ont
jamais confiner les pays actuellement
pas en place par gand ce moment les
restaurants sont ouverts pour regarder
la courbe elles baissent et elles
baissent même plus vite qu'en france il
faut donc si vous voulez si c'est vrai
alors c'est pas bien sûr cette émission
on me dit les chiffres sont faux les
chiffres sont vrais niasse chaque fois
que vous prenez les pieds dans le tapis
ensuite parce que la dépouille aurait
vérifié mes chiffres dépend des tapis
fini les tapis sont épaissis vous les
prenez bien les pieds de blanc mais à
chaque fois donc ne dis pas que c'est
fou j'ai vérifié mais la grève et 3 ou
filippo la grèce est en confinement
depuis le 7 novembre et hier le ministre
la santé grec a dit on n'a jamais eu
autant d'infection qui hier donc il faut
se poser des questions au bout d'un
moment on peut pas détruire le pays
détruire des métiers un art de vivre on
est la france le tourisme donc une par
ailleurs détruire nos libertés que c'est
insupportable de mettre les gens sous
cloche comme ça d' interdire des
manifestations de mettre en couvre-feu
etc
c'est juste insupportable pour une
démocratie digne de ce nom alors que ça
n'a pas de résultats sanitaires
vous avez des pays je peux en citer
plein à la bosnie l'inde l'india plus
une restriction depuis le mois de
septembre
et pourtant ça baisse la russie est plus
rien en ce moment et pourtant il n'y a
pas du tout l'explosion dont la france
donc moi je dis il faut faire il faut il
revenir au calme
aucun d'abord c'est une crise
multidimensionnelle c'est pas que
médical le politique si jamais vous la
dire sur les aspects économiques sociaux
à dernier trig moraux éducatifs
culturels tout démocratique
2 il faut revenir au calme c'est une
maladie qui tue des gens qui ont 84 ans
de l'âge médian ça tue toujours trop de
gens ici
la moyenne basse c'est fini ça s'est
terminé l'âge médian glissé sa main 14
80 mais c'est faux ces avancées nous
faible à croire que c'est 40 ans je vous
dis c'est une maladie qui table qui tous
très âgés
ce qui n'est pas plus excusable c'est
bien ce sont des morts tout à fait mal
se dégage un an - faut oui je dis ce qui
dans ces temps c'est vrai mais bon peu
importe il faut travailler sur la
prévention ne vous pourrez pas
contredire l'académie nationale de
médecine qui depuis le mois de mai
dernier le communiqué toujours en ligne
recommande la vitamine d faut travailler
sur les traitements il y en a plein y'a
plein de choses intéressantes l'inde
utilise l'ivermectine ya plein d'autres
solutions alors nous on autorise ici que
les traitements qui coûte 2000 euros
enfin notamment quand ils sont encore
qu'en phase 2 comme les anticorps
monoclonaux sa vraie pour sa première
intervention troisièmement arme ultime
de fermer des lits à l'hôpital
moi j'étais à nice l'autre jour monsieur
estrosi nous il nous faut nous en fait
des tonnes la sueur mais le chu de nice
ferme deux cents 200 livres et supprime
200 personnels en quatre ans mais qu'est
ce que c'est que cette histoire de faire
du chantage aux français verrons nous
fait du chantage à la saturation de
l'hôpital et en même temps ils
suppriment des milliers de vies chaque
année le comité a obligeamment traiter
les gens sereinement en prendre soin
prendre soin des personnes vulnérables
faire de la prévention
avoir un système hospitalier haut niveau
et arrêtées donné la liberté aux
médecins de x-men et de détruire le pays
et de faire croire que le confinement ça
marche ça n'est pas vrai déjà c'est
magique merci monsieur philippe aux
derniers invités prise cap thévenot qui
est porte parole de la république en
marche vous a répondu en toute logique
oui le gouvernement a bien géré la crise
du coronavirus mais néanmoins je veux
qu'on fasse avancer un peu le débat
parce que le principe c'est le conseil
de classe donc en revenir sur tout ce
qui a été fait est ce que vous
reconnaissez certaines erreurs dans la
gestion de la crise
là le dossier le plus ancien à la
polémique la plus ancienne c'est celui
des masques par exemple et là il faut
bien dire qu'on nous a expliqué que 1 ça
servait à rien madame ndiaye nous a dit
qu'elle savait même pas comment mettre
un masque à l'époque et on s'est aperçu
que c'est parce que nous n'en avions pas
et que maintenant on recommande le port
du masque est ce que vous êtes prête
quand même à reconnaître quelques
erreurs et d'ailleurs c'est ce que j'ai
dit en répandant la question c'est oui
le gouvernement a géré au moment et en
fonction des informations dont ils
disposaient mais est-ce que tout a été
parfait depuis le premier jour de l'ag
on a crise non on va pas le dire parce
pourquoi parce que le virus est arrivé
de façon quand même abrupte il est
imprévisible
donc il a fallu aussi connaître et le
dompter maintenant on peut toujours
continuer à dire que le virus d'ailleurs
est toujours imprévisible notamment avec
la connaissance qu'on a des variants et
des différentes variantes qui arrive
donc ça serait quand même assez étonnant
de dire que tout est parfait sachant qu
encore une fois on en train de dresser
enfin d'essayer de dresser un bilan et
c'est bien mais n'oublions pas qu'on est
encore en crise sanitaire
donc il ya encore des choses qui vont
arriver et j'espère positives mais il
faut regarder ça de façon pragmatique et
assez humbles maintenant moi je me
permets juste de ravir parce que je suis
obligé de réagir par rapport à ce que
vous dites vous pouvez sortir tous les
chiffres que vous voulez toutes les
études que vous voulez je comprends tout
à fait votre besoin d'exister dans le
débat public et votre errance politique
ne doit pas trouver sa réponse soit sur
ces deux éléments de langage et isolés
non je serais pris sur le fait sur le
fond la vitamine les vitamines vous
apprenez rien quand vous dites que des
vitamines à monsieur verront de le
dijonnais vous me posez une question
laissez-moi répondent ses personnages
pourquoi monsieur n'avait pas fini
d'écouter ce que j'étais en train de
dire mais c'est dommage
vous dites que les vitamines permettent
de stimuler le système immunitaire
message envie de dire qui va vous
contredire tout le monde le sait on
demande à nos enfants quand ils sont les
mais de là à dire que la matière mais
bah si mais non ne croyez pas ça
s'appelle une politique de santé
publique de faire de la communication
c'est vous c'est pas ça qui va se
développe alors une autre cordée jalel
je suis là nous voir dans margam merci
madame vous dit de méchant la vitamine
va permettre de limiter la propagation
du virus non et tous les traitements que
vous soulignez tous les deux justement à
très juste titre
effectivement vous et si madame enfin je
veux dire si un traitement était connu
pour effectivement nous sortir le plus
rapidement de cette crise sanitaire
mais qui est le gouvernement fou qui
aurait dit non sur tout le front des
colts ont été tués les je suis désolé et
donc est donc là on a un gouvernement
faible devrait bien on accepte que des
gens meurent tous les gens madame
les faits mais monoclonaux qui n'ont qui
ne sont qu'en face d'eux d'études vous
avez vu les articles ce soir du monde
efficacité discuter libération qui dit
divise les experts parce qu'on est qu'en
face d'eux alors qu'à côté des
médicaments 8 euros la boîte comme
l'hiver mais gleason ils ont beaucoup
mieux connue vous voulez arriver vous
mélangez tous ses lecteurs l'intérieur
le confinement sur quelles études vous
basez vous pour dire que le confinement
à l'inversé du bon sens ça s'appelle
dans le bon sens avec l'année les gens
en disant c'est mon sens